what do you like the most about the game
how buff I look and how I'll pick my
hair looks we got him to turn both of
those up just another notch than the
real and they've also made us a look a
little younger than we really are so
right it's been it's been fun to sit and
be part of designing your own sort of
cartoon character I guess my favorite
thing is probably having it yeah because
at least with the kids if right now I'm
like the coolest dad in town I was down
in LA about a month ago arm out at
Guitar Hero and there's an actual
there's an active position there that
you have us a job called a video game
player or tester and there was a guy who
was testing the drums out and I was
watching this guy play the Metallica
drums on expert level and I literally
ran screaming in the other direction I
was so terrified it's easier for me to
play guitar bass in the video games and
is to play the drums because when I play
the guitar bass I kind of look on the
screen and Let Go Go Go good when I play
the drums that kind of just play like
how I usually playing I feel like within
minutes you know I notice obviously like
there are other bands besides Metallica
yeah did you guys choose the band's
right oh yeah we yeah we chose all of
them yeah I mean they're all sort of I
don't like the way it I guess it's too
late to change now like oh it says guest
acts what's that that sounds so formal
that's a very formal right friends right
you know friends 20 20 friends of ours
the old bands that we chose ourselves
and on some of them are installations
and there's a practical thing that
happens in the wake of these games which
is like you have to find the master
tapes which is not always easy we didn't
know where you know a couple of our
records master tapes word then some
people they have to rerecord them then
there's all kinds of publishing
and then you talk to one band and you
say well we'd really like you guys how
about this song and then they go well
that has different you know lineup than
the kind of this all kinds of horseshit
that you have to deal with names like
Slayer and Judas Priest and system and
merciful fate and Skinner and queen and
so on all part of this whole thing that
says metallic on it too oh yeah do you
think this is like sort of a new format
of like the album like releasing a video
game I would say that probably if we sit
here at south by southwest in 2014 I
think there's a good chance that that
many more records and that that it will
be considered almost like a normal thing
to do I mean my kids listen to black
sabbath and it's a deep purple and two
system of a down and so on because they
discovered them through the video games
they didn't hear deep purple on the
radio I think it's too early to start
kind of having these definitive answers
about like and what's it doing in terms
of bringing kids in the direction of
matching pink guitar or singing or
whatever the thought but certainly from
my own experience I can see that that
it's making kids more interested in
music and I think in 2009 music needs
obviously as much help us it can get
you